[Music]
[Music]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was over the past year
I've learned how to Mitch McConnell
wrote tune out my critics Rahm Emanuel
wrote carve out time just for me
Toronto Mayor Rob Ford wrote hold
tranquilizer darts out of my neck I love
my dog so much
I let him Charlize Theron wrote sleep in
my bed Aubrey Plaza wrote ride in the
front seat Nicolas Cage wrote pick my
movies
[Applause]
when the director first called me about
the movie Noah Jennifer Connelly wrote I
thought this sounds interesting Russell
Crowe wrote I realized I always wanted
to do a biblical epic Larry King wrote
he asked me if I wanted to play myself
what's that I'm being told Larry King
has just sent in a video response to
that last survey let's roll it that joke
was so low it almost hit my testicles
[Applause]
anyway when this horrible hiccup he got
that video in fact hey when this
horrible winter ends it means Cameron
Diaz wrote people can start coming out
of their homes and enjoy nature again
Joel McHale wrote my friends will stop
complaining about the snow on their
Facebook pages Bruce Jenner wrote I'll
finally be able to switch to my
lightweight summer face sometimes it's
really hard for me to get out of
Harrison Ford wrote signing autographs
Robert rice wrote political fundraisers
Wilford Brimley wrote coffins stop
burying me
[Applause]
Oh product placement is okay when it's
greg kinnear wrote subtle gwyneth
paltrow wrote organic Colonel Brian
wrote a nutrigrain fruit
[Applause]
I took Latin in school because dr.
Sanjay Gupta wrote I wanted to become a
doctor
kat dennings wrote I thought it would
help my SATs Larry King wrote I grew up
during the Roman what's that Larry King
just sent in another video response
you're going to hell Colin I know
because I went to high school with Jesus
[Applause]
when Alec Baldwin announced he was
leaving public life William Baldwin
wrote I applauded him for his decision
Stephen Baldwin wrote I told him he had
my support Daniel Baldwin wrote I am the
chunky one and constantly constantly
reminding people that I'm not Jessica
Biel wrote Jessica Alba Zooey Deschanel
wrote Katy Perry Steven Tyler wrote
dryer lint that's come to life
and finally the first time I saw the
stones was Whoopi Goldberg wrote in
Chicago Vince Vaughn wrote at Madison
Square Garden Lavery camera when the
oceans receded what you're kidding let's
take a look that joke is older than me
I just reached in to eat a nutrigrain
bar on the way out and they've stuffed
it with an old rag why can't we have a
real box what is this stuff with an old
rag I don't understand this show at all
it's a very nice rag though yeah oh yeah
I'm gonna treasure this forever
all right folks we'll be right back